retour à l'école virtuelle dans une
famille de quatre enfants
est dit lemay et sébastien pelletier
gère les horaires et plusieurs rendez
vous virtuel pour trois de leurs enfants
de 6 9 et 10 ans
des parents qui ont un certain
entraînement disons que c'est un peu le
bateau s est touché
depuis l'arrivée surprise de micron ils
sont comme des milliers de parents qui
pèsent les avantages et les
inconvénients d'un retour à l'école la
semaine prochaine
ou encore à la garderie pour le petit
laurent avec l'école ouverte se pose
quel genre de ce monument c'est tout le
temps les mesures s'est jamais ok lui
son école je relis faire un test est ce
que les autres doivent rester à maison
il faut tous qu'ils s'isole et ça change
tout le temps à la maison mais au moins
c'est ce qui s'en vient pour un petit
peu plus près mot même si tu le sais que
ça passe c'est tout cela est certes le
au quotidien pour moi je trouve qu'à luz
plus que de vraies bagarres on est en
maison pour deux semaines je capable de
planifier non north harbour et deux
prochaines semaines puis j'ai l'horreur
des enfants
nous avions rencontré la famille
pelletier le 13 mars 2020 le jour où
tout a commencé
le gouvernement annonçait alors la
fermeture des écoles et garderies pour
deux semaines pendant s'organiser le
parce que là nous on essaie de
travailler en même temps ça fait presque
2 1 puis on s'arrange montre que ça
finisse
depuis il dit.le mais a perdu son emploi
au cirque du soleil
travailler trois mois ch et celle des
grâce au programme je contribue et
retrouver un autre emploi on veut de
nouveau
oui on était chanceux on a la cage vide
on est une belle tribu nombreuses
choisir entre le risque lié aux contacts
ou le chaos prévisible de l'école à la
maison léo aussi est ambivalent mais
pour d'autres raisons que je n'ai
l'école à la maison et vielmon plus est
à lesquin j'aime les deux qu'il n'y a
pas de bons scénarios je pense que juste
des scénarios - pays qui était le
scénario moins pire pour moi c'est
probablement le scénario pire pour une
autre personne parce que
on va faire avec
comme à l'école ses deux parents qui
sont en télétravail prévoit les
essentiels période de récréation
ici à nourrice despatie radio canada
boucherville